ما في السماوات وما في الارض الذي يش
يعلم
[Silence]
في
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم الحمد لله والصلاه
والسلام على رسول الله واشهد ان لا اله
الا الله واشهد ان محمدا عبده ورسوله
اللهم صل وسلم وبارك على نبي نبينا محمد
وعلى اله واصحابه اجمعين
اما بعد
اما بعد يقول الحافظ النووي رحمه الله
تعالى في كتاب رياض الصالحين في باب الصبر
وعن ابي هريره رضي الله عنه قال قال رسول
الله صلى الله عليه وسلم ما يزال البلاء
بالمؤمن والمؤمنه
في نفسه وولده وماله حتى يلقى الله تعالى
وما عليه خطيئه رواه الترمذي وقال حديث
حسن صحيح
ابي هريره رضي الله عنهم
الله صلى الله عليه وسلم
[Silence]
نفسه يعني في جسده بصحته
وولده
وهذا يشمل ايضا عائلته
في ابيه وامه وولده وازواجه
وماله
المال في لغه العرب
هو يطلق ويراد به جميع ما يمتلكه الانسان
ليس هو فقط
اللي احنا بنقولها الفلوس و
النقود هذا من المال او الحق بالمال
تغليبا
حتى يلقى الله تعالى وما عليه خطيئه
الله تعالى not any
صلى الله عليه وسلم
in himself in body
in property andth until me not any sin
to for why is that he has no sin to
الله سبحانه وتالى
‏pa is where
is
nar in chapter of pa not chapter of
tribulation chapter of patience meaning
‏for any difficulty
to have the of a person sin is that they
are patient
that they are patient and patience has
many levels
that the schars have mention
there are instances where a person will
have a tragedy strike
‏and
are
what they are notent
number
are
thee of
this iem
‏I do not agree
with the decree of Allah
I feel and then people you know they say
many things they start to come up with
many reasons to justify this. ‏feel that
they're not getting a fair shake.
They feel it's unfair. They feel
it's unjust. They feel it
should have happened to someone else and
not them. They feel they're being
picked on. They're being you know
singled out etc.
‏this kind of
this willate
pa
who has this
belief or has this reaction this
invalidates a person patience and now
not only do they have the tragedy but
they have the tragedy with no with no
reward or expiation show for it second
الله سبحانه وتعالى
هذا القبول
was
not
‏This is lowest level of the threshold
of pav
that above that that mention is that a
person is not only accepted has not only
accepted what has occurred
الرضا
بقضاء الله سبحانه وتعالى
فعندك الاول المتسخط
هذا محرم وهذا
ينتفي به الصبر
القبول
مع عدم الرضا
وفوقه الرضا بقضاء الله
[Silence]
هو الرضا والقبول
والشكر لله على على
الاجر والثواب
[Silence]
‏CR
all comes in order to
come make worبا
ان له
‏are
الله سبحانه وى
صل الله عليه
‏was
put and
comp asked him you know why are youing
they thought this these tear will
invalidate a person not so there are two
is here number
الله
[Silence]
صلى الله عليه وسلم هذه رحمه جعلها الله
في قلوب عباده وانما يرحم الله من عباده
الرحماء
[Silence]
‏time ان شاء الله اسال الله سبحانه
وتعالى ان يلهمنا صبرا وان يعلمنا ما
ينفعنا وان ينفعنا بما علمنا والله اعلم
وصلى الله وسلم على نبينا محمد